Today I'm going to show you how to setup an HTTP or HTTPS load balancer.
First navigate to networking.
Now navigate to load blancing.
Now click start configuration
in the HTTP/HTTPS Load Balancing section.
Fill in the name of your load balancer.
You can use lower case letters, numbers, and hyphens.
Click backend
configuration to configure where your incoming traffic will be redirected
From the drop down menu you can select an existing backend service or
you can create a new backend service.
Now enter the name for your backend service.
From the backends section
select an instance group. Finally
select a health check from the drop down at the bottom.
Click and host and path rules from the left panel.
The first row determines where any
traffic not explicitly with a host and path rule will be sent.
Click Add host and path rule to add
a second row. Now fill it in.
Click frontend configuration to configure the protocol, IP address,
port and certificate if necessary
Click the create button to create your load balancer.